what's up with you guys thanks for
coming through yeah what do you guys
live that's great
born race I'm glad you guys came through
so what's been going on anything good so
everyone's dropping project like every
second right I remember the first one to
like my phone buzzed and I was like it
was the only time my phone ring was on
in the last 10 years like I said there
was I was so pumped it happened on a
Saturday and how have the prop house the
project doing
of course every every every projects
kind of different you got to speak your
truth yes supporting that go do your
thing
yeah how about for you yeah I was
working with our religious Whigs I work
in advertising and we just kind of came
across each other just working together
and then I thought a month to do like
three or four more bodies and I'd work
with a ton of artists but it was working
with images and I'm against it
yes and how are you thinking about that
is that is that what you want to or
trying to figure out yes
which must feel interesting huh yes
options yeah exactly people want me
personnel you should do a podcast
hosting the party
why do you think he did that you think
he loved it or he just thought it was
economically the right move for him I
love do I understand but it's
and what are you doing advertising our
where you've been in the agency world
for a long time and before that
yeah I've heard this person is close by
to say to see you next year that worked
great cuz they don't the sign the
contract I couldn't agree more
it's the biggest thing I noticed when I
first got in started Manor I didn't
realize what people would tell me yeah I
don't know yeah that's right these are
these you know all the agencies the
company work for right now is a huge
publicly traded company I don't give a
[ __ ] about you your line item and so
yeah this is I've said this before I
don't know if you ever heard me say this
Julie I'm and this is the truth if I
actually understood the advertising
industry is dynamic between employees
and the holding companies I would have
never started vaynermedia that's real
life cuz I hate when people leave my
company I hate it I love continuity you
even know the way I talk like well yeah
like I'm really trying to figure out how
to make it forever or at least a long
long long time so that when it happens
it feels like cool and like awesome and
right not oh I need to be at a place for
18 months and then leverage and now
because our brand is so strong a lot of
the kids
do you think I know that are coming in
this is a great launching pad because
it's a good brand right now and like you
know the more traditional shops want you
know kids that were grooming people get
caught up in short-term thinking you
know people just people are confused by
abundance people think that they're they
need to take something that somebody
else is gonna get without realizing
there's so much for everybody to eat
tonight America's gonna throw out more
food we get it then we literally the
food that America throws out tonight
could feed so many parts of the world we
just don't think we think of things in
silos there's so much more to go around
and everybody's grabbing because they
think like that's the only like it's all
around us and I just watch it and I'm
like I never think that somebody's
victory is at my expense if I was a
rapper like literally if you know
whoever has the biggest song in the
world right now I would never think oh
my god that dude or that woman is
getting all the listens okay like you
know what I mean that's how people act
like like you know just talking about
current hip-hop like I don't I would
hope that the Mikki Minaj or the people
around her don't sit there and say well
cardi B's taken our listens
I understand it's an easy lazy thing to
say if you're not thoughtful if Nicki
Minaj puts out a [ __ ] fight or track
right now we're gonna listen there's
abundance there's abundance
but that's the confusion in the system
you know and so people need a
calibration of understanding it how much
food there is to eat and I think
everybody needs more empathy to me
that's so stuck in my right here right
now houssam with a new label you're
gonna be a different version of yourself
than if it's the third label third you
know album with a label because you may
for your own ambition and skill set want
to prove something or start off at the
right way or so there's so much context
in every interaction in every
transaction that's what I spend all my
time on empathy I think so but it's also
why I think I have rare results
basically it's a very basic business
thing if you can survive doing it the
way that nobody else is doing it if you
have the ability this is what I have to
sell it to keep you alive to give you
leverage to then be able to afford the
thing that everybody else does you win
that's the story Boehner we could stay
alive in two thousand nine ten eleven
twelve doing social media when nobody
wanted to buy it because companies the
world like I got five thousand a month
for you for [ __ ] four full-time staff
do social media a full rack but I could
stay alive and then it became the market
and I mean so how we're gonna build the
biggest media property we're gonna pull
the biggest media agency on the back of
doing all the stuff right and then we're
gonna buy a television shop commodities
that's where the dollars are now but as
that goes like this that will all die
even though it's even to the spend and
let's say Facebook and Google but I'll
be able to buy it because the
infrastructure costs are gonna collapse
it Toys R Us does plenty of revenue it's
out of business
like you know plenty of people make a
million dollars a year they just spend
1.1 million
antwuan woke Walker made a hundred
million dollars yeah it doesn't matter
how much you make that is what you spend
you know so spent a lot of time thinking
that way
it's how I think about attention by the
way so I think about making things
successful you know what are you gonna
spend it this this for me is a bad use
of my short-term time what they're
paying me for this one pilot episode
over three days there's a bad use of my
time in the three-day period but if it
pops yeah it's gonna hit an audience you
know I'm gonna win the Internet it's
like if you know over the last 15 months
you guys know like and in the next three
years they'll be even more I'm gonna win
but they're still at least for now
you know 49 year old Karen you know I'm
not gonna get to heard of the way I'm
gonna get as being like a star Joe so
it's just trying to figure out the right
pieces anything I can help you guys with
you know I'm some aware about your yeah
I think Bo Jackson I'll tell you why you
can always do the author you can always
default into picking one or the other
but if you can do bojack's n' creatively
and like filling your soul like to me
that to make a binary decision that now
I'm gonna just play them like my you
know you have these abilities and that
it's what I'm doing I'm doing all sorts
of [ __ ] because if I can you know what
the reason I wouldn't do this show is if
I felt like last year proved to me that
I wasn't capable but that didn't happen
I feel like I am capable I work a lot
which allows me to kind of like close
the gaps on doing things I also know
what this means to our business you know
so you know to me you know here's how I
think about music and I really wish I
had that skill set in today's
environment of distribution the fact
that I could get inspired go into the
[ __ ] studio break off a song and
literally just drop it on soundcloud or
Spotify and use my own social to build
awareness and if it's real and if it's
like God like literally somebody who
builds awareness that has some social
and has the ability to produce a song
and nobody's in charge of your
distribution or your marketing and then
you let the music speak for itself is
remarkable
I mean I'm 42 when I think about like
going and getting signed by a label
producing an album the marketing the
Virgin [ __ ] mega store selling your
[ __ ] MTV or BT having to give you love
or z100 like all that's gone the middle
is dead you your audience SoundCloud
Spotify upload for [ __ ] free let's go
are you [ __ ] kidding me so you could
be personality you could be disagree
nope nope nope nope nope nope disagree I
get it
cuz you're [ __ ] musics fire and they
want more music but the fact that they
even took the time to go on Twitch and
tell you that is already suck
never worry about people that are
talking to you worry about the people
that stop talking to you my daddy's
think it's super like been kind of shape
that we got a complaint I'm like dad I
love complete you know what perfect I'd
want to hear everything cuz what I'm not
hearing it I'm not in control when
somebody came to Wine Library back in a
day and didn't have a good experience
like me I'm dangerous as a customer I go
to a restaurant if the waiter [ __ ]
punches me in the face I won't say a
word I don't know how to complain but I
just will never go back like the way to
punched me I would like like suck my
bloody lip eat my food leave not talk to
the manager not make a scene not if you
look at all I don't know how many tweets
I have not one complaint you know many
times I've had shitty experience not
[ __ ] you Delta not [ __ ] this nothing
I don't have it in me it's not how I was
raised right what I do is like she's not
to go back write to me if somebody
saying they're mad at me believe I care
means they're still in the circle means
I can learn from it to me it's the
people just unfollow never said anything
about it got it so you know like to me
when you're getting that feedback it's
only showing love to a skill you have
and they just want to be fed some more
but I don't think that's the reason to
stop doing something I think that's the
reason to do all of it
is a farce yes I do
I think a lot of these sayings are from
times that don't exist anymore for
example fake it to you make it can't
fake it to you make it anymore because
while you're faking it it's your public
domain like you can't come if you're
gonna come out and say you're a 22 year
old life coach like that's you can't
fake it like you used to
everything's being documented
everything's both being watched no I
don't think so man I think a lot of
people are multi-dimensional I also
think you're in a funny business if
you're in the music business
you're one at-bat away from everything
she's your one song away every day your
life you can't brother why do you think
I'm talking to you
you can't walk away from a game that
literally one [ __ ] song in your back
it's acting too John Travolta was dead
for sixteen years and then pull fiction
my man so [ __ ] that you can never give
up on music you know one [ __ ] song
away very
it now it also depends on your artistic
you know process a lot of stuff is easy
for me because I'm straight improv like
Judy and I can go pitch right now our
biggest piece of business in the history
of LA and I'm not gonna prep she'll be
ready I'll be ready without what I have
to be ready for it you know I'll be I'll
be ready for what I mean I don't I go
out there I don't know anything about
the business I pick ups that I don't
know any like I can pick up [ __ ] for my
list in three seconds I'm I got you like
that's what I'm good at
so I would have been like I always wish
I could rap because I'd like I'd be
great for me I'll just go and [ __ ]
spin it from the top of my dome be out
no writing no nothing I'll just go do it
it's why I want like one of the biggest
reasons I want this to pop is I just
want
cuz I'm like yeah if I'm like I think I
would kill it yeah we'd kill it I feel I
think my opening dialogue would like
motivated generation and then I go and
do some funny [ __ ] and like I'm pretty
[ __ ] what was the first oh yeah oh my
god
what is this she heard that I'm doing
yes she's like that I hope she's gonna
pitch me I'll buy that's it man that's
the answer I believe in it I think it's
not that I think it's that bad here's
what I think about you I don't think
you're capable of putting out something
that is detrimental to you that's what I
don't think people understand I think
you're too talented from what I know
about you to put out anything that's
detrimental in my and you know this I
put out my heart and and this is what
the rating they gave me things that you
thought were gonna be the song that was
gonna change your career nothing songs
that you didn't pay attention to meant
something I do it with content to like
I'm like this is gonna be the fire and
it's like I'm not like what happened
like you know that's so common that's so
right it's advertising to like you know
it's it's the way the world actually
works it just means it's it's to me it
just leaves so much to me creativity is
like I'm fairly creative in the scheme
of things now that I've gotten to know
myself a little bit as I've gotten older
like but like I don't know I just like
you can't man affecting this happened
this morning we walked in here he's like
can you put on for the vlog for the vlog
I'm like we can't feel much here so I
was like unmotivated so I literally took
it off which I never do I was like I
don't want to do this right
literally
or four minutes later off of reading
something in my Instagram I'm like dear
ox let's go make up an item now because
we do the vlog I rarely do what I did
three years ago which is get inspired
ask somebody for a camera to come and
see me and I would rant my content in
2012 to like 15 most of the YouTube
thing would be I was inspired luckily
somebody was on camera I'd rant about
something like Wall Street's wrong about
this or I believe Twitter's gonna do
this right now I never do it cuz we're
filming everything and I don't need to
and I don't think that way this was the
first time I've done it in six months
ago oh yeah we did actually but anyway
nonetheless four minutes earlier I'm
like I don't want to be miked four
minutes later I'm like I want to make an
original piece of content off the top of
my head that's how I think about music
now which is like you know like how
amazing is it if you can just do it when
you feel it and not be confined to the
creative or the distribution I mean
that's it you got it that's it man [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that and now especially if
you're a G and a twitch community do you
[ __ ] like you hate you just make a
like a like a crew if ninja is listening
to your [ __ ] while he's playing for
tonight right now like that's more
listens than [ __ ] I Heart Radio is
gonna give you people are confused man
people are [ __ ] confused
this is MTV 1984 people confused the
biggest bands in the world didn't make
music videos because they thought it was
giving away free music didn't get it
they were think it's short term Stix
didn't make music videos they were one
of the biggest bands in the world
because they thought it was free music
[ __ ] you this new thing MTV we're not
gonna [ __ ] make music you're gonna
play it our people have to go to the
record store and buy her [ __ ] until
nobody knew who they [ __ ] they work is
Duran Duran and Van Halen and [ __ ]
and Twisted Sister were playing on
[ __ ] loop and then they became the
biggest bands exposure listens some kid
who's got [ __ ] two million people
watching them play for tonight playing
your track while they're playing is a
hell of a lot more than Z one [ __ ]
hundred they can't
hanging out with the tank yep yep that's
my home I'm a drink entire movie star
jury that's the fortnight equity right
yeah he was like yo you know how I did
China but my leg what might kill me even
get our music in this guy's game it was
like we don't give a what
music I'm like this guy's name is gonna
be and no one believed me and I'm
hanging out with all the streamers and
I'm like yo they want to be able to play
our seniors how we think about media you
know it's all I think about what
commedia overpriced underpriced they
think courting [ __ ] pitchfork is like
like I don't can [ __ ] about anything
like any established thing doesn't mean
anything it doesn't have the leverage
its leverage is overrated its leverage
is overrated
whatever the establishment is overrated
I don't know what to say
but it's great now that switches the
thing but you know for me I've been
doing it for two years would be like
what is this video game I will say his
name but a famous rapper whose
management many buddies a friend of mine
blew me away how much should we charge
twitch a year ago I mean you don't
charge twitch they want us to stream on
their thing I'm like you should do it
because yeah Amazon's bought them for
980 million dollars I know what I'm like
how do you not know they flew me in and
like tell them educate them about twitch
but they still didn't just learn but now
direct it is like of course it always is
gonna be a moment snapchat until you
know Khaled do it yeah Twitter before
Ashton Kutcher jumped on it's all the
same [ __ ] game we know it's happening
but the but the culture and the
mainstream need that moment and I just
spend all my time trying to be at that
moment beforehand so when the moment
happens I get it I mean I was I almost
did twitch before I did you - but
stunwin yeah before you would even run
my team don't know three and a half
years ago like you know
we streamed the words rapper 25 hour
stream on Twitch and we did it at the
same time posted on YouTube and Twitter
it's not a cool guys twit twitches
continuous minutes trump everything yeah
I'm thinking about just going twitch
$0.24 I might just [ __ ] just live
stream live for the rest of my life on
Twitch just go back to go back to what
it was which was done by Justin's I mean
this is a iJustine that's how she blew
up yeah you know Justin TV iJustine TV
like she was like was she was the
Justine like that's how she blew up back
in a day to me it's just so much
underpriced attention you go and DM 55
influencers on Instagram with 2 million
followers and ask them to just put a
minute of your music in whatever video
they're using it's just more exposure
than z100 I don't notice to tell you
it's nothing personal you know like it's
nothing you know I'm sorry like I don't
know like would you rather be a Netflix
hit show now or you know a Bravo hit
show Netflix five years ago Bravo 10
years before that CBS 50 50 years before
that [ __ ] radio channel XYZ before
that drawn in a cave like [ __ ] changes
right like I don't know like that number
one drawer caveman caveman Jon this [ __ ]
is fly right attention moves MTV's bump
was 1986 nothing was more important
everybody music energy just sat in a
room me like I read this music video was
gonna make us or not right yeah so I
mean I'd much rather everybody would
torrent my latest book I don't want the
money I want the attention
I do it all the time I go on all these
like shows and like hip-hop shows about
they got you got a new book out like
ever and you know the host is trying to
do right but Charlemagne will be like
you everybody go out and buy and I'll
jump right in but like no no don't buy
it go download that [ __ ] for free you
know and then the audience were say no
and then I guess they loved that
[Music]
you